[Music]
are you sure it has enough salt I feel
like it needs more salt
no okay wait go ahead I'll be doing TV
and now we're whipping all the eggs
together hi I'm Yara and that's me
cooking Iranian food with my mom in
episodes 1 & 2 I spent some time with
LA's Iranian community also known as
Tehran jealous to talk to other Iranian
Americans about living and growing up in
the US and now I'm going back home to
figure out what being Iranian American
means to me and how my family's story
plays into all of this I'm one of the
estimated 1 million Iranian Americans
who live in the u.s. I was born and
raised in Northern California but like a
lot of Americans with immigrant parents
I sort of have this dual identity on the
one hand I'm very American but I'm also
very Iranian here in the States both my
parents are small business owners my mom
runs a clothing boutique and lives in
San Francisco my dad owns a subway and
lives in our south he came to the US as
a teenager to get an education
right before Iran's 1979 revolution a
few years later when Iran was in the
middle of a war with Iraq my dad went
back and married my mom together they
moved to the US and eventually had me
over here my dad subway we go inside and
see what he's up to
my dad's owned this place for over 30
years
I practically grew up here and I had a
lot of his sandwiches especially on my
birthday's my dad's been here so long
that he's really gotten to know his
customers and the pigeons outside my
dad's definitely changed while living in
America
before he wanted to move back to Iran he
almost always spoke Persian and he hated
having dogs in the house now he happily
lives in the suburbs
mostly speaks English happy holidays and
Happy New Year and loves dogs
yeah but Iran is still very much a part
of who he is we even found this under
his carpet before my dad came to the US
the Iranian Revolution was picking up
steam he was getting involved with the
protest and his parents were concerned
for safety in Iran the things was
changing you would see people come to
them the streets and going against the
Shah of Iran all of a sudden my father
came to a house he says it's time for
I'm here to go to United States I was
almost 17 why did he say that because
they said if Amira stays here he may be
killed
back then in 1979 Iranians made up the
largest group of foreign students in
America there were over 50,000 of them
but then the hostage crisis happened
that's when Iranian revolutionaries
determined to end US influence in Iran
held dozens of Americans captive for
over a year in response President Carter
cut diplomatic ties with Iran and
temporarily banned most Iranians from
entering the country and all the Iranian
students already in the US had to report
to immigration authorities to prove they
were legal several thousand were
deported back to Iran as anti-iranian
protests took place across the country
in some cases immigration officers
showed up to people's homes
there was somebody knocking at the door
and there were four guys in a in a
two-bit three-bedroom apartment and
there were two gentlemen with the Thai
blue shirt
yes we are here from immigration office
and we gonna check all the passport all
hours were shaking maybe they wanna
poor guys you never told me about this
I've never heard this oh it was so
beautiful
my dad earned a master's degree in
mechanical engineering here in
California but when he finally got his
green card he didn't have much luck
finding a job in his field
which is how he ended up getting
involved with the subway so what you're
gonna have to do you get some yogurt and
then I'm gonna add a little bit of
saffron to do good
who taught you how to make these things
my mom she was and he's excellent cook
yeah she's my grandma I used to be
watched him for like minutes hours it
would you know it smell of it it makes
me nostalgic still takes me back did my
mom grew up in Tehran when she came to
the US with my dad after graduating high
school they thought they'd only be here
for just a few years but Nate year war
had broken out between Iran and Iraq
moving back to Iran had to be put on
hold
my mom did go back to visit during the
war what she saw of her country shocked
her
everybody was mourning everything was
black the cemetery was full people were
sad you didn't expect to stay in the
United States oh no I had no desire I
was homesick I was missing my mom simply
my mom my girlfriends from high school
my dad my home my parents got divorced
about 20 years ago but away from her
family and on her own my mom started her
own business
[Music]
and we'll philosopy the concept of
operating this business I think it's
more of the Persian or Middle Eastern
than West and poor we sit and we talk we
have tea together and have sessions
together Iranian culture has also played
a part in how my parents raised you when
you were born we are B both of us try to
raise you that with the Iranian culture
always be on your mom thought because
one day we gonna go back to Iran we were
talking Farsi - yeah we me and your dad
we never spoke English to you
the only time you were getting exposed
to English was when you were watching
cartoon TV what was that like what was I
watching Barney's the purple character
every morning huge thing Barney's
Barney's Barneys
Barney Barney growing up we go back to
Iran when we could I wasn't too crazy
about it as a kid but developed a huge
interest in going back as I got older to
the point where I moved there for two
years to work as a journalist and
translator after college there was just
something unbelievably wholesome about
the unconditional love I'd received from
my enormous family something about Iran
just sucked me in maybe was because I
sometimes felt out of place in America
and wanted to flesh out this other side
of my identity even still I didn't feel
fully Iranian in Iran people told me I
spoke Persian with an American accent
that my hand gestures totally give away
my American identity or that the way I
thought about things was different but
growing up Iranian in America had its
hurdles to see favorable to you well
there was one instance over playing
soccer and I remember this kid and he
looked at me this was after 9/11 I think
I'd maybe kick to the ball and properly
and yeah he looked at me and he's like
oh yeah that terrorist so I know for me
like the Iranian identity always came
through
no I am very obviously different looking
and different maybe sounding and maybe I
have a funny name right my tiara LM
Julie like what is that you know people
where is that from right no no I like it
no I love it today but back then when
you're kind of trying to blend in it's
it's different right I remember you told
me one day I don't like my name and I
said everybody loves your name everybody
thinks it's such a beautiful name what
should I have called you you go David I
stuff between all these names
David why David mm-hmm David is cold I
said well how about the meat at least Oh
Dawood my parents haven't lost sight of
their Iranian Asst but they've now spent
far more of their lives here in the US
than they ever did in Iran my dad ended
up getting remarried to a Salvadoran
woman and now I have two sisters here's
one of them as you see I am 58 years old
almost 17 years in Iran almost 39 years
in United of David now today I have a
choice of packing and moving back there
I have a choice I'm living here what
choice have you made this is home for me
here in California this is home for me
the Iranian America doesn't matter we
live in LA or we live in New York we
came here as a student we didn't want to
stay here but this country made us love
this country and beloved nobody can
separate funny yes is our identity we
can be our two arms you want me to cut
what I can't
you want me to cut this image this is my
America
I've talked a lot about feeling
in-between in this series and some sort
of limbo between one identity and the
other but talking to my mom and my dad
it got me thinking maybe I don't need to
live my life feeling divided and in
between maybe I can firmly and
confidently embrace both identities
simultaneously I mean in a sense what's
more American than that okay so I just
put my family on display for you guys
hope you enjoyed hearing about my story
as a child of immigrants but now I'm
going to turn over to you
what's your family's immigration story
like and how has it shaped who you are
don't forget to subscribe and watch out
for our next episode where we break down
some myths about the Iranian American
community